الان رغم التحالف الوثيقه بين روسيا
وبيلاروسيا الذي تحدثنا عنه الا ان وثائق
مسربه قبل ايام الكرمل اظهرت ان موسكو
تخطط للسيطره الكامله على حليفتها مسك في
اطار انشاء مشروع روسيا العظمى الجديده
وفقا لما نشرته صحيفه تيليجراف البريطانيه
مشروع الكلام للسيطره على بيلاروسيا بحسب
وسائل علم غربيه قائم منذ ما يقرب من 24
عاما وكان ينظر للمشروع المسمى دوله
الاتحاد على انه اتفاقيه تقوم على المصالح
المشتركه مع ذلك اشارت الوثيقه الى ان
روسيا تواصل توسيع وجودها العسكري في
بيلاروسيا حتى يصبح دائما وعلى ان تمتثل
القوات المسلحه البيلاروسيه لللوائح
الروسيه واشارت التسريبات الى ان الكرملين
يسعى لتوحيد اوكرانيا وبيلاروسيا كجزء من
روسيا الاتحاديه واشار سفير الولايات
المتحده لدى منظمه الامن والتعاون في
اوروبا الى ان اهداف روسيا مع بيلاروسيا
مماثله لاهدافها مع اوكرانيا الا ان
الفارقه الوحيد انها في بيلاروسيا تعتمد
على الاكراه وليس الحرب كما هو الحال في
اوكرانيا التوتر مع روسيا يمتد ايضا الى
اين مولدوفا الجاره الجنوبيه لاوكرانيا
قبل ايام نشرت صحيفه جاردين البريطانيه
تقريرا تحدث عن ضروره ان يتنبه الغرب
للهجمات غير المباشره التي تشنها روسيا
على مولدوفا اضافت الصحيفه ان مولدوفا
بحاجه الى المساعده الغربيه لوجود مؤشرات
على استعداد روسيا لاستهداف جاره اوكرانيا
الاستراتيجيه مع استبعاد الاجتياح المباشر
والاعتماد على اسلوب اثاره الاضطرابات
ومطلع الشهر الجاري استقالت الحكومه
المولدوفيه المقربه من اوروبا بعد
اضطرابات اتهمت موسكو بتدبيرها وفق اجهزه
الاستخبارات الغربيه خاصه في ترانسيستريا
الانفصاليه المواليه لموسكو والتي تنتشر
فيها وحده عسكريه روسيه بشكل عام تتعرض
مولدوفا لهجمات الكترونيه وهجمت اعلاميه
روسيه كما اغلقت البلاد مجالها الجوي في
الايام الماضيه بعد تحذيرات امنيه من